all she needs to say is he sexually
assaulted me he did something and then
it's he said she said and I had lose my
job I lose my income I can no longer
support my boys that does not happen
it absolutely happens if you're on any
kind of social media I am sure you've
seen the hashtag me too
if I were to say me too what's the first
thing that comes to mind good intentions
bad ramifications when I hear the term
meets you I think of some people that
have been rightfully taken down I also
think of some people that have been
wrongfully cancelled a lot of men I
confused about what it really means and
they take it as sort of like an anti Men
thing or like an attack on men when it's
really definitely not think that not
enough people get the alternative
perspective on issues like me to which
they seem to think is pretty radical can
I don't necessarily think we're that
radical I guess I'm hoping for
understanding as to what an tied me to
means we have this moment where one of
the biggest predators that was named and
me too from the beginning will face
trial so I think it's inevitable that
there will be another big wave of energy
around this house I'm Justin I'm 21 and
I majored in sociology my name is Sydney
I'm an American Australian youtuber and
political commentator Mavi I'm a
creative and a community designer hi my
name is Chelsea I'm a community
organizer and activist hi my name is
Dave Sussman
I am a co-host at America's voice live
in America's voice news and I have a
television show called whiskey politics
my name is Blair away I'm a youtuber I
also do at social and political
commentary so can I get my hiromi to
group over here on the left and my anti
back there on the right the me to
movement is a witch-hunt
yeah I feel like every good intention in
the world in me getting but I feel like
it's it spiraled a bit and there's been
some people that have been sort of
wrongfully cancelled as we say Aziz
Ansari comes to mind who was cancelled
for not basically reading the mind of
the woman who withdrew consent after
having sex with him I feel like people
shouldn't be collateral damage and rape
accusations really destroy someone's
life it's a paradigm now where you have
men as the universal perpetrator and
women as a universal victim that's for
me when it's become and I just think
it's usually problematic and I mean how
can you vilify like half the population
men are not even allowed to be a part of
this dialogue a lot of men are abused in
incorporations
so it isn't just about women it is about
the abuse of power I have a big issue
with the term witch-hunt it feels like a
very convenient political term to sort
of distance ourself from what's really
happening in the me2 movement so so what
would you term it as though I think it's
a movement to examine the power
structures and the very real ways that
people are falling victim to predation
that is upheld by a criminal justice
system that allows it to continue to be
the case but I think that there is a
similarity when you consider the fact
that many people who support the hash
talk in the movement they really do set
aside due process which is really what
happened to women during the actual
witch hunts I think that a lot of times
and you see hashtags like believe all
women believe women and there's no
nuance and that just has to be the case
but when we get into you're not saying
believe some women or you're not saying
not all men that we're not really
getting at the core of the issue which
is the abuse and it's not saying like
men are all bad or anything like that
but it is saying that maybe we should
examine the people who are empowering
since Muslims power people in power are
men then perhaps we should examine the
dynamics and gender and everything like
that
I think that there's definitely a space
for discussing sexual assault sexual
harassment and I think that's awesome to
bring it to light but I think that it's
become pretty toxic as a general topic
because I think it's become something
that's more about vilifying men than
necessarily helping people I mean think
about the entire process right from the
time an incident happens until a moment
where some form of justice is received
the onus is on the victim the survivor
to navigate the entire system right so
we're talking about having to share your
truths which is the darkest experience
you've may have ever been through police
reporting the evidence collection is an
extremely excruciating process for
people and so often we don't even have
the funds available to do that I know
schools in Los Angeles weren't even able
to do rape kit testing on campuses and
then you look at the facts and data that
so few people end up in jail so few
people even get their day in court and I
think - I mean again how you said it
puts onus on the victim or at ease you
have to prove that something happened to
you and what's difficult about that is
again a lot of these situations are
happening with people in power
I mean if two people in the room
together and there was like no witnesses
or no anything then it's already I mean
you already disbelieved because it's
your word versus theirs
what about the thousands of men that are
accused in corporations that we've never
heard of before
that may not have the socio-economic
power to defend themselves not only in
court but also in the court of public
opinion and maybe they were falsely
accused how do you prove a negative how
do you prove that something didn't
happen when it's a he-said she-said
well I think we're getting a little
twisted though I thought the criminal
justice system was innocent until proven
guilty
would you it's supposed to be and it is
because it means that the burden of
evidence is on the person who was trying
to say you know the me2 movement in
September of 2018 were standing outside
of the Supreme Court banging
on the door saying that the man is
guilty and he should not be nominated a
Supreme Court justice based upon what
that the whole fourth fifth and sixth
amendments were completely ignored on
that no due process whatsoever so I
would I would love to have Brett cabin
I'll have a day in court and that hasn't
happened right because there was no
proof provided so what are you
protecting he's innocent then right then
why did half of the population of the
United States mostly on the Left
including they're complicit media make
it sound like that this man was the
devil incarnate and they believed it
period no new wants no evidence new
leave all women exactly he's what I'm
hearing is oh well it ruins lives and
he's on the Supreme Court currently and
what I'm not hearing you guys talk about
is like the death threats that Christine
Blasi forward received after her to me I
just think there's this assumption that
oh you can't disprove a negative but
really it's easier to say that this
woman is coming forward or this man is
coming forward because they want to get
get ahead in their career than it is to
say that this person who we've trusted
in our company this person who we
trusted in this industry has been
abusing that power for years how is it
that all of these women are all of a
sudden just coming forward maybe they're
coming forward now because there is a
space and maybe because of the nature of
trauma they are just now really kind of
like addressing what had happened to
them I'm a rape victim I was raped at 18
I understand that you don't really come
to terms with that sometimes until like
a while later like I wasn't able to like
really be like say the words I was raped
until I was probably 23 24 which is like
five years after the harsh reality is if
you don't seek justice immediately you
don't get a rape kit you come forward 20
years later there's not really gonna be
much of a case for you so I think what's
really important is that yes
like supporting people who come forward
with accusations but also teaching
people of any gender that one thing that
if that happens you you have to
immediately seek help to me it's like
revolutionary in this
of giving power and voice to people who
are kind of told to be silent because
it's more comfortable for society and
for predators who may be in powerful
positions I fear false accusations I am
a big proponent of equality with women I
don't want to be because I'm on the anti
me to side here classified as a
misogynist I believe that the me to
movement has swung way too far and a lot
of men that I know are deeply concerned
about and I refer to the Harvard
Business Review study that just came out
three months ago that suggested that
fifty-eight percent of men are deeply
concerned about being falsely accused
that's changed my behavior in my life
I will no longer date somebody in my
industry what's gonna happen in six
months or in a year from now when we've
had a great relationship and it comes to
its natural course of end and something
happens where she's got this idea in a
head that I did something to wrong her
all she needs to say is he sexually
assaulted me he did something and then
it's he said she said and I had lose my
job I lose my income I can no longer
support my boys that does not happen it
absolutely has not happen every single
day mostly due to our past okay it could
happen I think that you're talking about
well men are scared now to you know be
alone or whatever and I think that's
really just like men finally being held
accountable for the fur or maybe not
even held accountable just like be aware
of the space that you're taking up and
your actions so yeah we're talking about
false accusations and I've been falsely
accused of sexual assault and absolutely
nothing has happened to me my reputation
is not ruined I can get a job I can go
to school because I didn't sexual
assault anyone with all due respect
you're at a much different place in your
life than other people who have careers
who have jobs who have families you're a
college student and you are not at a
place right now where you're carrying
those responsibilities but I think I
think like what why you I mean if you
know you're a good dude and you don't
I know the women so for the past 30
years I've been working in corporations
and I've worked with a lot of phenomenal
incredible dynamic powerful women maybe
10 years ago I was going on business
trips and we were having dinners and you
know people are having drinks and things
can happen I'm not suggesting that
anything inappropriate happened but
today that would not be something that I
would entertain it's not about me being
uncomfortable it is that 58 percent of
men that's 60 percent almost of men
today say that they are uncomfortable
being in a in a business relationship
with a woman with they cannot be on a
one-to-one and that is impacting that's
impacting women in their ability to
progress in corporations and I don't
want to see that I fear false
accusations because when we actually
look at what a false accusation is it's
an incomplete accusation well I can be
lied to
or it's an accusation where the police
were unable to obtain all necessary
information in order to pursue whatever
truth was there you're right there could
be a small percentage of lies in there
but we also can't get blinded by what we
think or want to think a false
accusation is because it's politically
convenient because we want to you know
make it sound like well it's it's your
responsibility to ensure your economic
future so you know take it as a serious
threat that I don't want to be with
women in a space because of what's
happening I feel like all of us are
talking about real harm
like real harm and so it's sad that we
talk about false accusations and we
start throwing all these distractions
out there when there's real harm that we
could probably all be really good at
falling together I think that the me2
movement is an extremely important
subject changed our politics it's
changed our business and unfortunately
it's changing our culture impacting
younger men the idea of having
confidence to go and talk to a young
women that you find attractive that
builds confidence in men and if they
don't get that confidence on that
they're not finding it elsewhere and
we're starting to see men turn inward
they're playing video games more they're
going to porn more they're not getting
off the couch and that's gonna impact
them later in life the lines between
harassment assault and rape are being
blurred y'all don't agree at all okay so
if you're in the workplace and somebody
puts their hand on your waist and it's
unwanted and you go to Human Resources
the person who did that could be accused
of sexual assault now if you get any man
on the street or any man a woman on the
street and say to them so-and-so was
convicted of sexual assault in that
person's mind that's the same as rape
yeah okay and so yes there are a
tremendous number of levels that are
going to differentiate the seriousness
between the hand on the waist which is
unwanted and should be should should be
dealt with if somebody touches you in a
way that you're not comfortable with you
should say to that person I'm
uncomfortable with you touching me this
way
there was a study that was done in
Australia on college campuses that
basically tried to measure how many
women have experienced or well it had a
very small fraction of men in that - but
it was predominantly women how many of
you experienced sexual assault and
things like that on campus and the
number came back and it was very high
what they'd included in that was like
leering like someone leering at you and
so I think that part of the problem is
that none of this is cool like none of
it's okay none of it is acceptable but I
think what's happening is that we're
conflating these things that are not on
the same page it doesn't inflate the
numbers and makes things look much worse
than they actually are and it doesn't
reflect the reality of how things
actually are these things that you
consider to be less than wearing
touching harassment versus rape like by
saying that there is a really it is it
is less but there it is in general as
I'm trying to say when you're grooming
someone and this is something that
people do they test little things like
if I look at her in a way that makes her
uncomfortable
or or them or him in a way that makes
them uncomfortable how are they going to
react if they don't react so that then
you're constantly these are seen as
green lights by predators to increase
that behavior this is my issue with
people who are anti me - is that they
look at small details and say that that
takes the power away from other things
when you say that 81% of women have been
sexually assaulted
including leering and someone entering
your body which is rape okay so let's
take away the second way that's creating
an area very that's 25% now those
numbers have been debunked as a father
as a mother would you ever send your
daughters to college knowing that one in
five chance of them being raped why are
women beings girls young girls being
sent to college with those statistics
well here you go again you're denying us
economic opportunity and like upward
mobility because of a situation that
happens if that's that's so far out of
that's the question that you're asking I
just I challenge the question because it
comes from a place of denying women
upward mobility based on a situation
that we can't control I think when you
look historically we've had such limited
ways of talking about unwanted and
unwelcomed behavior that happens to us
so I think it's a really amazing moment
actually that we're in that that the
language of leering and rape are put on
a spectrum but they're not anyway on a
spectrum they're they're lumped in as as
the term sexual you're talking about
media's limited you know ability to
communicate these things but what you're
challenging it based on me too but here
we are me too and Here I am dealing with
nuance so when you say currency that
nuance is it's not here it's not a part
of the conversation you're increasing me
I think you're I think you're actually
an anomaly in a lot of this because when
you talk to a lot of people about this
topic you get this very overarching one
way is the highway perspective when you
have these figureheads that are saying
81% of the population that is a woman is
you know gonna be sexually assaulted in
our lifetime and not breaking down what
that means that's huge and then you have
young people who are being influenced by
that so no it's it's it's like
intellectually dishonest to run with
something like that and the worst part
is sorry Blair
all we ever talk about is women I am so
sick of hearing about women I hate the
fact that you know women are they
experience this but I how about we talk
about what men go through for a hot
second because I will tell you now it
will probably be in the same frequency
men are raped in the home at the same
frequency by women as women you're
totally right and it was one of the big
failures early on ur than me two
movements that it centered the stories
of white women explicitly I say here is
why
women that it was really focused on
celebrity like they need more media
attention and more power at their backs
and meanwhile hotel keepers and house
workers and there were so many people
who are experiencing the same types of
power dynamics on smaller scales but are
never gonna get the media spotlight the
media wants to create a victim they want
to create cliques and so they use the
most sensational headlines so that they
get those cliques context does matter
because when you're talking about
individual human beings they have their
own lives and I'm not talking about a
louis c.k who's got millions in the bank
I'm talking about some guy that's
earning 50 60 100 grand a year that
could barely survive I think we agree on
a lot more than we disagree with here me
too was a way for survivors to find each
other and to connect I'm so supportive
of the need to find connection in some
of the darkest experiences people have
in their lives and for the movement
where it's going today I think there's a
great need for accountability and to fix
some of the most broken systems in our
country today I have been personally
affected by sexual harassment and
assault
yeah I myself in college my freshman
year I was raped about two months into
college actually if parents knew more of
what actually happens when college
campuses then yeah maybe they wouldn't
be sitting there girls to college and so
to know that I went to a school that
purposely were misrepresented the
dangers on campus and also did not have
resources for people that like things
did happen to statistics on these things
are kind of dismissed because people
think that it's not possible and it is
possible because it is in the best
interest of these institutions to sweep
these things on it around because where
are they going to get their tuition
money from where are they gonna get you
know your government funding from if the
real numbers do come out there have been
like two instances one I absolutely
don't want to talk about but the other
one actually like I ended up pressing
charges
and you got thrown out of court because
[Music]
yeah I mean like it's really funny
because I'm over here like I don't think
things are on the same other things
impact you in like bizarre ways
yeah like because the perpetrator wasn't
white um and because he was like I'm you
know part of like a certain religion and
when the police are basically just like
we can because of cultural differences
which I don't feel like is such a great
reason for like throwing something else
so that was that was one of the weirdest
hardest most I guess insulting
experiences to go through but it's funny
because we're talking about all of this
the thing that keeps coming up for me is
one of my best guy friends we've been
friends for nearly a decade I don't know
how it came up but he goes um oh yeah I
know I was sexually assaulted and he
just brushed it off like it was nothing
and he said like it doesn't matter he's
like it's fine this just made me think
of him the entire time and how under
ordinary circumstances he just would be
dismissed I think what was said was
really interesting about how trauma like
affects you in different ways like I was
raped like pretty brutally when I was 18
and I like convinced myself right after
that it was somehow my fault because I
was on a date with this guy who was
quite a bit older I think he was like 30
and I guess when I was getting
passionate earlier about like things
like leering getting away with rape it's
because it's almost insulting it is
insulting to act like there's something
not that I think you guys do at all yeah
that's me I was very deeply like
triggered worried but like um brought
back that memory of being touched on my
back in a way because that was like how
I was held and the moment something
happened to me and it was really hard
for me to like accept hugs and like all
the like positive touch I needed after
that happened because it instead like
was taken from me as a positive thing
and turned into a negative and it was
like it just sits with you it's whether
it's dormant or active and present its
with you
first of all thank you for sharing your
stories ladies it certainly impacted me
the reason I did step forward is because
what I thought that happened to me was
not sexual assault or rape because at
the time I thought I enjoyed it and I
warranted it in my mind so I look back
and I don't look at that as an assault
on paper probably it is it most
certainly as anybody that abuses their
power should be held accountable
so conversations like this I think are
really good they're productive they're
important thank you ladies for sharing
your stories and hopefully we all gain a
lot out of this I think that violence
and harassment and sexual assault
against women is happening at
disproportionate levels we're not saying
men it doesn't happen men or I can't
happen men or it's not important when it
happens to men we shouldn't hear men's
voices me too is for us as well like we
benefit from it just as much as you guys
do but I think we probably agree with a
lot more with each other than things we
disagree
thank you great job